hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow flash mid-season
finale q and A's so many wtf's so we'll
get through it during a lot of questions
about who Harrison wells is and what's
going on with Oliver just a reminder the
flash and arrow are both coming back in
the same week the flash will be back
january twentieth arrow will be back the
next day on the 21st so just careful for
spoilers from both of the episodes if
you haven't see him yet but starting
with questions number one make 11 asks
what was up with Malcolm videotaping
phia killing Sarah and Sarah didn't say
anything about it not to mention
Malcolm's phone is it a fake video no
it's not a fake video he wasn't filming
it on his phone so Malcolm was probably
just filming her murder from a long
distance and then uploaded the video to
his phone he probably wasn't using his
phone to film it he just had the video
on his phone question 2 I will one asks
I hope we get to see Roy get the
spotlight while arrow is out and seeing
Laurel and black would be great yes we
will see both of those things Roy will
very much get the spotlight while
Oliver's away we don't know how many
episodes exactly Oliver's gonna be gone
probably a couple at least in present
day we might see him in flashbacks Roy
is gonna fill the gap he asked him to
take care of Thea but he is going to
take care of everything that Oliver
normally does except for that love
triangle with Ray Palmer I think we're
always going to pretend like that
doesn't exist that would be a pretty
funny site so Felicity I'm going to have
to stare longingly into your eyes for
the next five minutes because Oliver
said to do all the things that he used
to do funny thing about that Emily BETT
Rickards and Colton Haynes in real life
have been seen a lot outside the set
question number 3 zens or tasks why
would oliver and rach work together and
if they did how did they fake the blade
going through Oliver's chest and if they
did how did they know that he wouldn't
bleed to death or break his neck during
the fall that's a good question I don't
think that they were working together
buddy buddy but I do think that Oliver
had a contingency plan one possible
reason for them working together is
because something funny is going on
inside the League of Assassins and
raychelle goal wants to find out what it
is I don't think that's very likely I
don't think they were working together
at least not in the sense that people
think they are like they're not buddies
but I think Oliver definitely had a plan
going into that fight and I think it
went down the way he thought it was
going to go down
as far back as season two he mentioned
how big Rashad goal was like what a big
deal he was so he knew that he probably
would lose the fight and I don't think
that they faked anything I think he
really is on the edge of death like he
just got a sword shoved through his
belly I wouldn't be surprised if it does
for some crazy reason turn out that they
were working together that rach
penetrated his stomach in a very non
critical place they did that during
Sherlock series 3 where one character
shoots another character to make them
look like they're dead but the bullet
enters in one of the few places where it
won't actually kill them generally with
big things like this there's always
something going on underneath there's
always like a side plot that we don't
know about till later it's a bit of a
bait and switch thing but it'll be a lot
of fun whatever the explanation is
question for ativan asks will you be
doing a video on Mark Hamill joining the
flash not right now I probably will do
some more rogue videos whenever it gets
closer to his episode there's gonna be a
lot of the Rogues in the back half of
the season mark hamill said this funny
thing on Twitter when john wesley shipp
congratulated him for coming back he
said this time we'll get it right and of
course John Wesley Shipp said well we
got to right the first time you know
they're just trying to say that as silly
as it was during the original series it
was still a very good show I think any
actor working on a show should believe
in what they're doing even if after the
fact it seems a little bit silly it's
just everyone geeking out on the fact
that they're making such a fun show I'll
probably do more about his character
when we get closer to that episode it
sounds like based on the amount of
episodes they filmed so far it'll come
sometime after episode 14 so sometime
between 14 and 20 I don't know how many
episodes exactly the flash is getting it
might just get 22 or might get a full 23
episodes arrow usually gets 23 episodes
which is a lot so sometime between 14
and the finale I don't think he's gonna
be in the finale question 5 Eric Jaffa
when Oliver Queen is dying he thinks of
his father his mother's sister felicity
when he was being watched by Deathstroke
in season 2 he told Felicity that Laurel
isn't the love of his life she is he
wasn't pretending yes Stephen Amell said
some really important things about
Oliver's final moments on the mountain
he said that his thoughts crystallized
about all those people all those things
so he said Oliver had a moment of
complete clarity where all of his
feelings crystallized in that moment of
death or the moment before death or
whatever looks like death meaning that
when he does come back he'll be acting
differently based on those feelings like
that moment is
I'm just processing okay this is the way
I feel about all these things these
people namely Felicity being the final
moment so whether you love it or you
hate it there will be more olicity stuff
going on in the back half of the season
whenever he does come back although it's
not going to turn into a soap opera or
anything like that interesting to note
though Brandon Ralph used to star on a
soap opera just like jensen ackles from
Supernatural always like big genre
actors that came from soap operas like
you never think it it's always funny to
watch the old footage even though
they're great we love you brandon
question number six jean-luc asks if the
teasers the CW posted is any indication
i theorized that merlin takes into the
Lazarus Pit and either turns Oliver into
his own killing machine with the drug or
manipulates him by some other means it
also makes me wonder if there's someone
else working with Berlin in the shadows
who could have taken him to the pit
after Oliver shot him in season one like
China white maybe I do think the China
white will be involved in a present date
in some way but I think I'll have
something to do with the bio weapon I
don't think that Oliver is going to be
using the Lazarus Pit I don't think
they're gonna be doing that storyline in
the episode 9 promo like the video promo
we just see footsteps walking up so
clearly someone is going to find him
help nurse him back to health probably
with a combination of medicine I don't
think we're gonna see green fire Lazarus
Pit that's a bit of a long shot I mean
I'd fall out of my chair if we saw that
I think we'll see a lot of metaphors for
his journey on the island this is
another crucible for him Stephen Amell
whenever he's talking about Oliver
people getting costumes always talks
about crucibles the island was a
crucible Hong Kong is a crucible now
this mountain is a crucible he'll come
out on the other side of this on the
other side of death in this case much
stronger with a vastly more crystallized
outlook on his hero's journey question 7
2 kappa source as we already saw
crossover with the heroes do you think
there'd ever be a crossover with the
villains as in villains teaming up or
possibly even against each other yeah
well we'll totally see like a rogue type
crossover with the arrow on the flash
eventually i kind of consider the
Suicide Squad episodes vil and
crossovers just because you usually get
a couple of them in there but I realize
what you're talking about you're talking
about like big villains I think
eventually yes we will definitely see
something like that in a much bigger way
this season though just because things
are kind of getting started with the
flash I think the crossovers will just
be internal like you'll just see
villains from arrow working together
and you'll see villains from the flash
working together the best example of
that on the flash is the Rogues one of
the episodes is going to be like a
rogue's revenge story that's what all
the promos for the next episode are
episode 10 of the flash whenever it
comes back in the spring it'll be a
rogue's episode Deathstroke is coming
back in episode 14 but they didn't say
how he might still be in that prison he
might have escaped we have no idea the
last time we saw Captain Boomerang in
the crossover they said they stuck him
in the same Argost prison that Slade's
in I'm really hoping that they actually
do something together like they break
out together that'd be so awesome
question number 8 Millie Joe asked what
was the best finale of the mid-season
arrow flash shield or Gotham while
flashing shields are amazing i think the
arrow punched me in the fields yes I
definitely the arrow was my favorite but
i think that flash has the better
villain all the mid season finales were
great Gotham is still finding its legs a
little bit it took its sweet time
getting to Arkham I wish it was at
Arkham the whole time I wish it was just
an arkham show Gotham is fun Arkham way
better agent to shield finally got to
Inhumans totally a huge leap from the
comics I think it's really awesome that
they're using the TV show to introduce
that even if we probably will never see
the royal family and the flash does have
a better villain I feel like Tom
Cavanagh as a villain is a better
character than rachel is on arrow right
now but to his credit he has been in
every single episode so he has had so
much more screen time to develop that
character then Matt nable has had to
develop the rachel gould character so i
might have to reassess which show has
the best villain after all the seasons
are over but the reason i picked arrow
is my favorite is because they killed
their main character like they had the
guts to do that on screen even if you
know big twist he's not actually dead
question number 9 Daniel asks what if
Laurel was secretly affected by the
particle accelerator explosion I don't
think that she was but that would be an
interesting thought she'd be just closer
to our comic book version of her
character we're just gonna see her get
her ass handed to her for the next
couple of episodes it's not as simple as
putting a costume on and calling
yourself a superhero that's part of what
her journey is Stephen Amell explained
that they're not gonna make the leap to
her being Black Canary right away they
wouldn't do that even though she's gonna
have the costume she's not going to be
very good at what she does right away
question 10 consuming fire asks what is
going on with Wells was that his future
self interacting with his
present self it depends on which version
of Harrison wells you think Harrison
wells is obviously I think that's a
pseudonym I think he is the future
version like the most future version I
think the simplest explanation is the
best he is working with the other
reverse-flash we saw whether or not
they're the same person remains to be
seen based on the way the Man in the
Yellow suit talked not Harrison wells
when we were looking at him at the end
of the episode he sounded like he was a
very intelligent person just as
intelligent as Harrison wells I think
what they did was a big act Harrison
wells wasn't surprised by anything i
would assume that it's a future version
of him and there's been some sort of
messing with a timeline thats caused him
to be stuck in the past it gets a little
confusing with time loose because if he
already got it and it's the same person
if Harrison wells is the man in yellow
and there's just two different versions
of him from different times why is he
stuck in the past that being said yes I
do think we'll see two different
versions of the reverse-flash it's not
going to be just professor zoom will
also see the hunter zolomon zoom I think
that Eddie Thawne is the progenitor of
that line I think that's why the
reverse-flash the man in the yellow suit
did not kill him because he recognized
that a lot of people are saying that the
man in yellow might be a future version
of Eddie but I don't think that he is
that smart one of the really important
things to remember when theorycrafting
is the idea of internal consistency
versus continuity hunter zolomon was a
great detective but he was not a great
scientist it is still possible that he
is involved so what I think is going on
is that Harrison wells is a very very
far future version of the reverse-flash
and the man in the yellow suit is
somewhere in between Eddie Thawne and
Harrison wells in the timeline like
Harrison wells is Eddie's grandson or
great-great-great grandson nematic Lee I
think it just looks better on the page
from a story perspective when everyone
is that closely connected it gives new
meaning to the idea of the flash family
question number 11 look nds on the
newspaper it says waynetech queen inc
merger complete but right now queening
doesn't exist anymore so yeah everyone
thinks that this is a bigger easter egg
than it actually is it actually means
nothing for the show it's just something
internally on the flash that denotes
whether or not the future has changed
the newspaper is the important thing
just the arrow Batman crossover isn't
important for the shows it's just
something funny that the producers did
it was never meant to
ply any future plotline they were going
to do question number 12 do you think
that any of the future flashes will
visit and help Barry like Wally or Bart
yes I totally think that's going to
happen probably not right away though
primates like season to season three I
think the closest we'll see to that as
soon as Wally West shows up and becomes
another version of the flash I think
that would be more of a firestorm
situation to where they're not in every
single episode but they are in like
three or four per season what I'm really
hoping they do is flash of two worlds
and he accidentally ends up on earth two
or something like that and runs into Jay
Garrick I think they will do a story
like that at some point thank you so
much everyone for leaving questions he's
always a ton of fun to do and leave your
requests for future bonus videos I'm
gonna start doing bonus videos next week
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're just finding me for
the first time big news from the set
Robbie Amell has been filming a ton of
flash he posted this picture really
recently of him standing in a field with
the three firestorm lights on it's just
that nucleus of an atom it's a firestorm
thing from the character in the comics I
think that means that we'll see him in a
costume by the end of this season which
would be just amazing there was also a
picture that Stephen Amell posted of him
on the set of arrow he had a wig on
Stephen Amell had a wig so it could have
just been him visiting or Oliver
whenever he comes back could have long
hair I think it was during a flashback
scene though just some things to look
forward to whenever the show first comes
back so we're gonna get the Rogues on
the flash they'll be back captain cold
and heat wave are going to team up and
then on arrow we're gonna see Black
Canary get her costume I have no idea
when Ray Palmer is gonna first put on
the atom costume probably to take a lot
longer for that one since Tuesday
Wednesday's are usually my flash arrow
days i'll try to post all my bonus
videos on those days but it's really
only gonna be gone for a couple weeks so
it's not gonna be that long right now if
you're on your mobile phone or on your
tablet there's new links you can click
on up here i think it's actually over
here it's the same as the links over
here but click here for my top five
racial ghoul stories from the comics and
click here for all my arrow flash finale
videos thank you so much watching so
that's all high five I will see you guys
tonight
you